Is Iqbal Survey
the funder behind Jacob Zuma's new political party?
I'm Rebecca Davis,
senior journalist for the Daily Maverick.
In mid December,
former president Jacob Zuma
announced that he would be throwing his weight behind
a new political party called Umkhonto West Sizwe.
It didn't take long for rumours to start circulating
about who else might be involved.
So at this stage,
we know very little about this new political party
other than that it is backed by
former president Jacob Zuma.
Its name is in Conte
where Cesare,
which is obviously the name of the a N
C's military wing during apartheid.
And for that reason,
it's a direct provocation
and the a N C.
Have said that they're going to be exploring
legal action.
Zuma has said that the party was established
after calls to him from religious leaders,
traditional leaders
and former m K fighters.
A document from the I. E.
C. Shows that the party was registered on the 7th
September 2,023
by a man called Jabulani Kumalo.
At the time,
Kumalo described himself as both a dissatisfied a N C
member and a former m K
fighter. Since then,
multiple figures from within both the a N C and m K.
Have come forward to say that this man was never
an m K combatant.
And given how difficult record keeping was at the time,
that is probably not an easy question to settle in.
In the interim,
it's been suggested that one of The funders
of this party is the owner of Independent Media
Iqbal Survey.
According to one widely viewed tweet,
survey has pledged
hundreds of millions of rands to this party.
Adamantly denying this charge is Iqbal Survey himself
who tweeted
for the record,
I have never funded
or been approached by this new party.
And survey also added,
with regard to my future funding
support for the 2024 elections,
I intend to make public
the organisations I intend to support.
So who is telling the truth here?
I hopped onto an online
database to see what I could find out about contraways
sees where's registration
as a company.
It was registered as a non profit company
and it has three directors listed,
one of whom is Jabolani Kumalo.
Another listed director has the same name
as someone who was arrested in 2020 for trying to steal
Sassog Social grants money from the system.
So there's no sign of Iqbal Survey there,
which is not surprising
if he's only a donor.
But the other factor to consider here is that Iqbal
Survey is not known for being a political donor at all,
at least according to formal channels.
Since South Africa's Political
Party Funding Act was passed,
there have been nine reports
in which political parties are supposed to disclose
all their major funders.
Survey and his businesses
have never appeared in those records. Obviously,
we can't know what's happening behind the scenes.
But Encanto Essex
where like all other registered political
Parties will be required to disclose
in the next financial quarter
whether they have
received donations of more than 100,000 rand
from any single source.
But the balance of probabilities here
suggest that this party has not received
hundreds of millions of rands in funding from survey
or from anyone else,
which is unfortunate for them
because that's probably the scale of funding
they would need to make a dent in this increasingly
overcrowded electoral field.